auf den weg in den bundestag wir wollen
die grünen auszeichnen für ihren
angriffen auf die einfamilienhäuser im
wahljahr ist diese idee sehr sehr mutig
und sehr sehr dumm will toni hofreiter
die deutschen aus dem paradies
vertreiben
sie sind von den grünen ja dann will ich
ihnen was überreichen die goldene eier
aus stahl dankeschön brauch ich aber
warum denn nicht sie bleiben doch immer
stehen noch mal sagen die grünen immer
stehen und jetzt haben sie abgaben sie
stehen bleiben sie stehen sie haben auch
nur angst die wollen sich noch nicht
äußern
endlich macht jemand der stehen bleibt
okay was die grünen in einer
legislaturperiode mit den händen
aufgebaut haben das reißen sie im
wahljahr mit dem hintern wieder ein oder
ja da haben sie recht und diese
steilvorlage die nutzen wir natürlich
gerne
sie freuen sich oder ich freue mich mein
halbes leben noch von den grünen nichts
gehört und das sagen so ein starker oft
war ja kommt mit einem eigentor das sind
wir natürlich dankbar das hatten wir
nicht zu hoffen gewagt in der nähe von
berlin treffe ich den selbst ernannten
könig der einfamilienhäuser er baut das
feindbild der grünen und das ist jetzt
das haus in dem der
durchschnittsdeutsche gerne wohnt
mangels den deutschen an geld oder an
fantasie zweitens weiß mit grau bei den
stadt will das bevorzugte das mögen die
deutschland nützen weiß mit grauen im
moment ist das fast jedes haus
da soll noch einer sagen die deutschen
sind langweilig hamburg
in dieser siedlung haben sich die grünen
jedenfalls keine freunde gemacht wohnen
sie in einem einfamilienhaus ja und
finden sie das ok die das jetzt sagen wo
die nicht selber einfamilienhaus ja klar
wären sie denn bereit noch jemanden in
ihrem haus aufzunehmen zum beispiel
einen grünen erst wähler in mein haus ja
ja das eh nicht genug platz ich würde
sogar mal monatlich auch nicht sie
würden selbst ihre mutter nicht auf das
haben sie denn eigentlich schon eine
bürgerwehr organisiert falls jetzt mal
hier jemand von den grünen vorbei kommt
haben wir bisher nicht gehabt und habe
sich auch nicht vor weil wir glauben
dass sich nicht 70 prozent der
bundesbürger so unterdrücken lassen dass
und befohlen wird dass man künftig zwar
die hühner rausholen die freilandhaltung
aber die menschen die so zurück in
irgendwelche acht geschosse sperren
wollen in hamburg gibt es kuchen das
fernsehen ist da und nette nachbarn
hallo das ist ja genau so schön und
kopie von einem plan aber es müssen
natürlich noch 34 stockwerke darauf dass
kriege auch jene also mehr flächen mal
gut der platz wäre dann natürlich nicht
für sie da würden danach familien
anziehen über ihn
okay okay okay ja ich habe immer noch
die möglichkeit nach frankreich zurück
zu gehen ist das ist französisch
übersetzt mal das heißt papa papa ich
will in die stadt ich will weg hier aus
dieser tristesse papa papa bitte das
haus verbraucht zu viel energie und wenn
jetzt die grünen die absolute mehrheit
kriegen dann wird der ganze bot sich
natürlich abgerissen oder man muss sich
anders behelfen kann man da fünf sechs
stockwerke noch draufsetzen kurzfristig
auf dieses haus nicht denn die statik
geschenk für ein einfamilienhaus also
abreißen abriss werden sie denn bereit
noch jemanden in ihrem haus aufzunehmen
zum beispiel einen grünen erst wähler
einen grünen er nicht er ist ja auch ein
holzhaus also schon ein bisschen öko
oder wird der grüne möglicherweise sich
auch wohlfühlen also das nicht dass er
sich festsetzt mehr verein nistet und
dann habe ich doch noch einen mutigen
grünen gefunden der das goldene bio eier
aus stahl
nimmt sie können sie mich ja mal in
meinem eigenen heim besuchen das wäre
doch auch die haben ein eigenheim
ja weil ich der hofreiter da natürlich
ich finde sie sind nicht mehr tragbar
wie heißen sie
gerhard krump sie wohnen im eigenheim ja
interessant sie verbrauchen den ganzen
platz die ganze energie nahrung für
siedlung und für mehr von allen das ist
natürlich es ist nicht eine zersiedlung
wenn man in einer bestehenden bereich
freilich gibt es hier oft gerade im
eigenheim braucht man das erst gerade im
eigenheim wird das jetzt gebraucht und
damit die grünen in zukunft wieder mit
mir reden die ich jetzt mal in
vorleistung studio
so aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich